[Musique]
tous les gouvernements finissent par
annoncer des mesures économiques
politiques voire électoralistes à
destination des classes moyennes
l'obstacle a une définition précise des
classes moyennes par trop sensible aux
hypothèses des courants théoriques ne
peut être dépassé qu'en résonant à
l'aide des concepts de classe médiane et
d'électeurs médian et de voir enfin le
sujet s'éclaircir pourquoi le politique
s'intéresse-t-il régulièrement au classe
moyenne en cause une forme de tragédie
de ces classes à la fois trop riches
pour être aidé trop pauvre pour pouvoir
se débrouiller seul le point bas des
classes moyennes demande à l'état
transfert et autres subventions le point
O pour sa part trop riche pour pouvoir
en profiter s'ajoute l'obligation de
participer via les prélèvements publics
au financement d'aide destiné
prioritairement et fort justement à plus
démunis pour preuve la faiblesse des
transferts non contributifs perçus par
des classes moyennes il en découle un
sentiment d'injustice aboutissant à une
remise en cause des politiques
économiques
du temps contre la pauvreté ou
favorisant le logement social accusé de
participer à l'éviction des classes
moyennes de freiner l'ascenseur social
ont telle raison de se plaindre ces
classes moyennes que l'on dit en déclin
à la peine comme un cercle dont le
centre est partout mais le périmètre
nulle part les classes moyennes se
révèlent plus réelles c'est une réalité
paradoxale qui parle à tout le monde
mais que d'aucun ne serait définir ni
instantanément ni précisément
officiellement population située au
centre de l'échelle sociale ménage dans
le niveau de vie est compris entre les
deux tiers et le double du niveau de vie
médian on évoque aussi une population
située entre les 30% des plus pauvres et
des 20% les plus riches au centre c'est
50% dans lesquels on distingue 30% de
classes moyennes inférieures et 20% de
classes moyennes supérieures impossible
d’ignorer l'évocation d'un ressenti de
déclassement il se lit dans l'auto
positionnement social des Français à 49%
dans les classes moyennes il se lit dans
la panne de l'ascenseur social si
génération à ce languir dans les classes
populaires avant d'accéder
la stratégie de ciblage d'un électeur ou
groupe médian capable de faire basculer
une élection en croisant dernières
intentions de vote révélées par ELAB
avril 2023 et dernier résultat de la
présidentielle de 2022 les classes
moyennes inférieures ici les professions
intermédiaires pourrait être le médian
générant jusqu'à une perte de 200000
voix au sortant sans compter la
déperdition en provenance de la
clientèle captive ici les classes
moyennes supérieures le politique qui à
l'instar de la plupart de ces
prédécesseurs ne s'adresserait qu'à une
frange des classes moyennes risquerait
une sanction électorale fondée sur les
regrets d'une classe qui s'éloigne de
plus en plus de cette douce séance
modeste et Aristote de signaler comme
une évidence pour lui que l'association
politique est surtout la meilleure
lorsqu'elle est formée par des citoyens
de fortune moyenne
[Musique]